[MUSIC]
A common question that
is raised is whether or
not an online program can actually be
comparable to an in-person program.
Because there's no difference
between the online and
on-campus diplomas, we go to great
lengths to ensure their quality.
>> Most classes in the program
are developed by the same instructors
that teach the classes on campus.
These are active professors that
are world famous in their fields.
And they're taking time to
develop these courses separate
from their usual teaching
responsibilities.
Many of our courses use
the exact same assessments and
graders as the on campus courses.
We know that courses are comparable
because both groups of
students are being evaluated on the same
assignments by the same Individuals.
>> We use state of the art technology
to ensure the integrity of the program.
We know that you're here because
a degree from Georgia Tech really
means something.
And we want to keep it that way.
We use cutting edge tools to
evaluate submissions for plagiarism,
to detect cheating during exams and to
ensure the identities of participants.
Every semester we're able to detect and
remove people engaging in unfair
copying of code or written work.
So you can rest assured that everyone
receiving a Georgia Tech Masters Degree,
whether online or
on campus has truly earned it.
In every way, we're working hard to make
sure that a degree from Georgia Tech is
a valuable credential, regardless of
whether it's earned online or on campus.